Дзеркальце-дзеркальце, скажи, та всю правду покажи:
хто найкрасивіша футбольна команда у світі?
Португальці цього року в гарній формі - в сенсі
пошитих на замовлення костюмах.
Гравці довкола зіркового нападника Кріштіану Рональду
з м'ячем, сподіваємося,  дають собі раду краще,
аніж з подарунками господарів чемпіонату.
Утім, з комерціалізацією команди все до ладу.
Попереду всіх - Рональду, який себе за своїми
ініціалами та номером гравця називає CR7.
Так само, як власні парфуми та власну марку спідньої білизни.
Решта команди виглядає на його тлі дещо блідо.
Приміром Пепе.
На футбольному полі йому не до жартів, але в рекламі
- чому й не посміятися?
Ми це оцінили трьома м'ячами.
Москва - місто фарб та розкоші.
Але не для російської збірної.
Єдиний костюм, який тут носять, схоже, лише тренувальний.
Тут вчаться тримати не модний стиль, а м'ячі.
Тож, від нас - лише один.
Французи як модна нація, звісно, мають зовсім інші підходи.
Гравці майже завжди виглядають модно і на "розслабоні".
Байдуже - в одязі чи без нього.
Попереду всіх -Пол Погба.
Улюбленець рекламної індустрії, 25-річний футболіст
веселий і трохи божевільний.
Але й він мусить підкорятися правилам команди.
А вона, схоже, витворяє на полі не футбол, а балет.
Для суперників - міцний горішок, якщо ті хочуть
переплюнути французів за стильністю та елегантністю.
Чотири м'ячі французьким балерунам.
Тим часом в Ісландії дме лютий вітер.
Гравці, можливо, і не на найвищому технічному рівні,
проте вражаючі ландшафти.
У найменш заселеній країні Європи грати у футбол не так просто.
Втім, населення країни обожнює свою команду.
Ісландські вболівальники на чемпіонаті Європі 2016 стали хітом.
А їхні войовничі вигуки - мало не торговою маркою.
Чотири м'ячі за ці мурашки по тілу.
Іспанія та її суперзірки.
Важко повірити, що тут обійшлося без зіркової хвороби.
Адже тут суперзірки одружуються із суперзірками.
Як Жерар Піке та співачка Шакіра.
А те, що співи - справа далеко не кожного, доводить
Серджіо Рамос своєю пісенькою до мундіалю.
Не дивно, що Марко Асенсіо та Андрес Іньєста
в рекламних цілях вдалися до втечі.
Можливо, саме тому тренер Хулен Лопетегі
передчасно складає із себе повноваження національного тренера Іспанії.
У співочому плані - груба гра. Тож, лише два бали.
Чинний чемпіон світу Німеччина демонструє сильний командний дух.
Також в модному плані. Тактика: багатоманітність,
як доводить Месут Озіл у новій рекламі.
Тоні Кроос позиціонує себе в рекламі зі своїм сином як люблячий татко.
Модель Маттс Гуммельс показує в рекламі модної марки,
що він ще й у футбол грати вміє.
Гламур притягує гламур. Воротар Кевін Трапп
закохався в бразильську модель спідньої білизни Ізабель Гулар.
А Жером Боатенґ показує, що можна гідно презентувати
пісню до чемпіонату і без того, щоб гарно співати.
Самоіронія зі стилем. Тому для нас це п'ять балів.